thanks ashley christmas with a dash of  magic the enchant immersive experience  is now open at the las vegas ballpark in  downtown summerlin a holiday event new  to las vegas but organizers are hoping  with so many events that it'll also  become a tradition for us local families  is the world's largest christmas light  maze it's also a local village market as  well as ice skating there's characters  there's live music and amazing drinks  he also says it took about 2 million  lights to put this together and the  focal point is a tree in the center  that's even taller than the rockefeller  tree this runs through january 2nd you  can even add ice skating onto your  experience tickets are on sale now